did you love the gumballs yeah I've know
the next morning I woke up and eat them
for breakfast I was pretty sick yeah I
like that
that's the wait and then I ate a PB&J I
was eating like a toddler but anyway
thank you for them yeah now you're
making me crave gumballs all right now I
want some too we should get some can we
just go and get some gumballs now yeah
okay we're waiting go uh I'll just wait
to do the anything yeah this movie you
know it's still thinking about and I
found something a reference the Frog God
is a frog I have heard somebody point
out the Frog I'm wrong but you saw it as
the mark of fertility
yeah the God is a fertile goddess of
variety you're pregnant in this movie
was it weird to see herself pregnant or
was it angelic first it was really fun I
was like look at this and then after
your back and feet started hurting does
they mean it was like 20 pounds if she
was silly but it was really heavy and
when you're pregnant I'm sure it's not
comfortable I've never been pregnant
before but when you're pregnant you have
time to kind of develop with the body
and with the belly and get used to the
weight I just come in the morning a hope
I really felt like a pregnant lady it
was like my feet are you good at decor
decor like decorating the house and oh I
actually really do I'm doing that right
now yeah and I actually just had a
decorating dream last night did you
there was a tree in my house it looked
like sir restaurant that's different
anyway
yeah I don't need to go to my dreams but
you're good I don't know what that means
well I mean I think I am that's my taste
and the brilliant Darrin he's so great
at this film and he's just unveiling off
the stuff that's happening in it what do
you love about him I mean what do you
love about his work I've wanted to work
with him for years cuz I think he's just
the boldest director of our time I think
he's so brave obviously brilliant I
think what makes him most interesting to
me is he didn't even get into filmmaking
like the rest of us do like I I want to
be a filmmaker he just had a story that
was burning inside
that he had to get out and every time he
makes a movie he's like a songwriter
it's just in him and it has to come out
and I just think I've never met anybody
like that I think it's incredible